und das verfassungsgericht ist so
geschäftsmäßigen sterbehilfe das andere
ist die korona anlage wir fangen mit der
sterbehilfe an paar fragen dazu und dann
kommen wir zum zweiten mal gespannt der
vielen dank wir sprechen bei der frage
der sterbe für über schlimmes leid das
menschen widerfährt wir sprechen über
menschen deren schmerz so groß ist dass
sie sterben wollen
das ist nicht einfach einfach
politisches thema das ist ein thema wo
jeder war der mit sich mit den menschen
mit den schicksalen dahinter beschäftigt
wo jeder spürt da geht es um mehr da
geht es um grundsätzliches genau deshalb
war es aus meiner sicht wichtig das
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
abzuwarten bevor sich regierungen und
parlamente erneut mit dieser frage
beschäftigen mit dem gesetz das der
bundestag 2016 beschlossen hat wollte er
sterbehilfe als geschäftsmodell
ausschließen
dieser generelle ausschluss ist nicht
mit dem grundgesetz vereinbar hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht heute
entschieden das gericht erkennt ein
umfassendes recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben an dieses recht so zitat besteht
in jeder phase menschlicher existenz
daran müssen wir uns orientieren wenn es
darum geht ob und wie der gesetzgeber
die sterbehilfe künftig regulieren will
das urteil gibt dem gesetzgeber
ausdrücklich spielraum zur regulierung
und konkretisierung
ich werde jetzt mit allen beteiligten
sprechen um eine verfassungs gerechte
lösung zu finden auch mit blick auf
beratungspflichten wartefristen und den
umstand dass je nach lebenssituation
unterschiedliche anforderungen an den
nachweis der ernsthaftigkeit und
dauerhaftigkeit des sterbe willens
gestellt werden können
denn ich finde es genauso wichtig dass
aus einem recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben nicht eine gewöhnung und in der
folge gar eine sich aus einer
gesellschaftlichen erwartungshaltung
ergebende pflicht zur inanspruchnahme
von sterbehilfe entwickeln darf wir
müssen immer die betroffenen und ihre
angehörigen im auge haben sie verdienen
es dass diese frage zufriedenstellend
und auch rechtssicher gelöst wird
gleichzeitig wäre es falsch
wenn behörden über leben und tod
entscheiden müssten
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat in
seinem urteil heute festgestellt dass es
eine verpflichtung zur suizidhilfe nicht
geben darf
aus dem recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben leitet sich kein anspruch
gegenüber dritten auf suizidhilfe ab für
mein verständnis
gilt das auch für behörden das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat nicht über
die auslegung des
betäubungsmittelgesetzes geurteilt
also auch nicht über die frage ob das
bundesinstitut für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte den erwerb eines tödlich
wirkenden betäubungsmittels erlauben
muss dazu läuft ein weiteres separates
verfahren
wir werden jetzt hier im
bundesministerium für gesundheit das
urteil und vor allem die
urteilsbegründung
ausführlich prüfen und dann entscheiden
welche schlüsse wir daraus ziehen für
die gesetzgebung und für unser handeln
als bundesregierung
es entstand der erste wagen die führung
bei der frage übernehmen wollen
ich denke es geht jetzt vor allem erst
mal darum dass wir alle gemeinsam und
ich weiß dass das auch die kolleginnen
und kollegen aus dem bundestag die er
teilweise heute auch anwesend waren in
karlsruhe auch tun werde dass wir das
urteil prüfen auch die begründung der
sehr ausführlich sein wird auch in der
herleitung miteinander prüfen und dann
wird man sicherlich entscheiden müssen
ob es ähnlich wie 2015/16 ein verfahren
gibt wo sich aus der mitte des
bundestages entsprechende regelung
vorschläge ergeben oder ob es möglich
ist weil das urteil so eindeutig ist in
dem rahmen den es setzt tatsächlich eben
auch einen gemeinsamen entwurf zu
entwickeln oder auch bundesregierung
seit ich einen vorschlag zu machen wir
werden sicherlich auch innerhalb der
ressorts der bundesregierung miteinander
dieses urteile auswerten müssen
ich denke am heutigen tag kann noch
keiner sagen abschließend wie genau
jetzt die weiteren schritte ländern sind
aber ich denke man muss gleichzeitig zur
kenntnis nehmen dass das
verfassungsgerichtsurteil jedenfalls den
weg eröffnet eben auch für einen rahmen
und für regulierung
aber wie geht es denn jetzt genau weiter
für die antragstellerinnen und
antragsteller innen man wie farm und
welches genau was meinen sie genau mit
dem weiteren separaten verfahren wenn
sie dazu noch sagen können ja zur frage
des betäubungsmittelrechts gibt es ihm
auch noch anhängige verfahren und zum
zweiten stelle gesagt dass wir im lichte
des urteils natürlich auch für uns als
bundesregierung und wir für uns als
bundesministerium für gesundheit
auch prüfen müssen wir mit entsprechende
anträge entsprechende anträge umgehen
was ihr bei ihm wichtig finde und das
ist ja das was wir dann auch abwägen
müssen ist das ausdrücklich festgestellt
worden ist dass es kein anspruch gibt
auch suizidhilfe und wenn es diesen
anspruch gegen dritte nicht gibt stellt
sich eben die frage aus meiner sicht
jedenfalls ob es diesen anspruch denn
dann gegen eine behörde und gegen den
staat geben kann das eine ist die frage
ob ich es erlaube dritten unter
bestimmten bedingungen möglicherweise
sterbehilfe zu leisten
die andere frage ist ja ob es für dritte
eine verpflichtung gibt
und zu diesen dritten zähle ich eben
auch behörden und diese prüfung werden
jetzt vornehmen fragen das trifft dieses
urteil was heute getroffen ist ihre
eigenen werte und moralvorstellungen zum
thema lebensschutz und die zweite frage
ganz praktisch wenn sie sagen egal ob's
regierung macht oder das aus der mitte
des bundestags kommt ist es realistisch
dass noch in dieser legislaturperiode
ein neues gesetz gemacht
zum ersten das ist ja leicht
nachvollziehbar ich habe damals für die
entscheidung für die gesetzliche
regelung gestimmt die heute vom
verfassungsgericht für ungültig erklärt
worden ist insofern können sie sich
vorstellen wie meine persönliche
positionierung zu dieser frage ist
nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts mit dem wir
jetzt natürlich auch umgehen wollen und
müssen und die frage wie schnell dieses
umgehend gehen kann ob und was in der
folge sich an gesetzlichen
entscheidungen er gibt das denke ich
muss man jetzt auch einfach in ruhe
besprechen wie gesagt innerhalb der
bundesregierung aber mindestens so sehr
ihm auch mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen im bundestag weil das ja
eingesetzt war das eben kein vorschlag
der regierung war sondern aus der mitte
des parlamentes ja auch erarbeitet
worden ist und deswegen halte ich jetzt
wenig davon schon wenige stunden nach
der urteilsverkündung und ich tippe mal
für die allermeisten noch nicht mit der
chance ist auch wirklich alles zu lesen
und nachzuvollziehen auch in der
ausführlichen herleitung schon zu sagen
wie schnell man denn möglicherweise dann
jetzt auch zu weiteren
entscheidungen und schritten kommen kann
wenn sie einverstanden sind würde ich
aufs zweite thema gehen
denn die lage in einer wg und baden
württemberg hat uns ebenfalls sehr
beschäftigt wir befinden uns am beginn
einer krone epidemie in deutschland die
neuen fälle in nordrhein westfalen und
baden württemberg sind dafür ein
weiteres zeichen die infektionsketten
sind teilweise und das ist die neue
qualität nicht nachzuvollziehen
es gibt eine vielzahl von personen die
mit den erkrankten kontakt hatten
und das ist eben ein qualitativer
unterschied zu den bisherigen 16
infektionen die wir in deutschland
hatten wo jeweils tatsächlich eine kette
und verbindung ja auch mit dem
ausbruchsgeschehen in china hergestellt
werden konnte vor diesem hintergrund ist
es fraglich ob unsere bisherige
strategie das virus einzugrenzen und
infektionsketten zu beenden auch
weiterhin aufgeht
deswegen komme ich immer mehr zu der
überzeugung die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
diese epidemie an deutschland vorbei
geht wird sich nicht erfüllen und nicht
ergeben
aus diesem grund habe ich heute in einer
telefonkonferenz mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder diese
gebeten ihre vorhandenen landes
pandemiepläne soweit noch nicht
geschehen zu aktualisieren und ein
mögliches inkraftsetzen vorzubereiten
am nächsten mittwoch werde ich mich mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen aus den
ländern dazu auch hier in berlin treffen
außerdem habe ich mich vorhin hier im
ministerium mit vertretern der
ärzteschaft der krankenkassen der
krankenhäuser der apotheker der pflege
und weiteren verbänden getroffen um
klarzustellen um miteinander zu
diskutieren wie wir angemessen auf diese
jetzige situation reagieren
wir haben uns darauf geeinigt dass bei
vorhandener symptomatik oder verdacht
jetzt besser einmal mehr auf das virus
getestet wird als einmal zu wenig am
geld jedenfalls und an der erstattung
der gesetzlichen krankenkassen für eine
entsprechende testung darf es nicht
scheitern
außerdem wollen alle berufsverbände
dabei mithelfen die öffentlichkeit und
ihre mitglieder weiter und noch besser
als bisher zu informieren
damit alle informationen alle plakate
alles was auch wir einen ansprechpartner
nennen können eben auch möglichst viele
bürgerinnen und bürger dann in der
konkreten situation und nachfrage vor
allem und dem bedürfnis nach
informationen erreichen können wir
empfehlen dem medizinischen personal bei
verdachtsfällen auch nach kontakten zu
infizierten sowie reisen ins
infektionsgebiet zu fragen und dann
entsprechend zu handeln und wir
empfehlen der bevölkerung den
bürgerinnen und bürgern nicht hinter
jedem husten eine corona infektion zu
vermuten dass sie aber ihren hausarzt
anrufen und die behandlung abklären
wenn sie innerhalb von 14 tagen nach
reisen in gebiete in denen infektionen
vorgekommen sind fieber husten oder
atemnot entwickeln
darum möchte ich sie auf dich bitten und
sie auch dazu auffordern oder eben auch
wenn sie kontakt hatten mit personen die
in diesen gebieten gewesen sind die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung hat
folgen erklärt dass er nach diesem
muster die ansagen bei der 11 67 der
telefonnummer die auch 24 stunden
erreichbar ist für den ärztlichen
bereitschaftsdienst entsprechend in den
nächsten tagen auch ändern und
aktualisieren will das begrüße ich
ausdrücklich denn er lässt eine weitere
informationsmöglichkeit für die
bürgerinnen und bürger bei nachfragen
sie sehen und das betone ich einmal mehr
wir nehmen das corona virus ernst
reagieren schnell und angemessen und vor
allem wir passen unsere reaktionen der
jeweiligen lager an und die lage hat
sich das muss man leider sagen in den
letzten stunden geändert herr minister
der föderalismus treibt ja auch bei
diesem thema seine blüten in welchen
ländern wurden denn die pandemiepläne
bis jetzt überhaupt umgesetzt in den
letzten jahren war das eher zunimmt
nicht der fall zu sehen dass da die
palme bleiben umgesetzt werden welche
länder sind denn jetzt wirklich nach
plan umgesetzt
wir haben ja auch aus den erfahrungen
der schweinegrippe vor etwa zehn jahren
insgesamt eine neue pandemie planung
insgesamt für bund und länder entwickelt
in den letzten jahren insbesondere
den jahren 2012 folgende alle länder
verfügen über landes pandemiepläne
insbesondere für eine influenza-pandemie
und die müssen natürlich auch die
aktuelle lage jetzt was die
besonderheiten des corona virus angeht
aber eben auch auf das jahr 2020 und die
gegebenheiten heute angepasst werden
mein eindruck ist dass viele länder sich
tatsächlich auch schon den letzten tagen
und wochen mit dieser frage beschäftigt
haben und mein eindruck ist auch dass
alle länder dass nun auch tun werden ich
will übrigens dazu sagen ausdrücklich es
ist in der pandemieplanung auch
vorgesehen dass krankenhäuser
pflegeeinrichtungen rettungsdienste und
auch betriebe unternehmen generell in
deutschland über pandemiepläne verfügen
und unser nationaler pandemieplan des
robert-koch-institutes sieht
ausdrücklich auch empfehlungen hinweise
vor eben auch für krankenhäuser
pflegeeinrichtungen rettungsdienste und
unternehmen
und ich kann nur daran appellieren dass
auch dort das habe ich gerade auch
gegenüber den vertretern dieser
institutionen gemacht dass auch dort
überall wo noch nicht geschehen die
jeweilige pandemieplanung bezogen aufs
haus auf die einrichtung aus unternehmen
aktualisiert angepasst wird und auch im
geschaut wird wo man tatsächlich auch
noch nachholbedarf hat
herr spahn
vielleicht können sie kurz skizzieren
was in so einem panel plan eigentlich
drin steht also was ist ein pandemieplan
was wird da was kann man überhaupt
voraus planen oder wofür kann man die
weichen damit stellen mit seinem plan
der pandemie plan ist ja kein geheimnis
sondern auch beim robert koch institut
für jedermann
verfügbar und ist eben sehr ausführlich
auch damals zwischen bund und ländern
erarbeitet worden und er enthält
unterschiedliche phasen wir sind ja im
moment noch in der phase wo wir alles
daransetzen mögliche infektionen sehr
frühzeitig zu erkennen infizierte
patienten zu isolieren damit es nicht zu
weiteren infektionen kommt und
kontaktpersonen aus den letzten tagen zu
identifizieren und dem auch zu isolieren
also die phase wo es vor allem darum
geht infektionsketten schnell zu
unterbrechen damit es nicht zur
eigenständigen infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland kommt und die nächste phase
ist eben eine in der wir noch nicht sind
von der wir aber angesichts der
entwicklung insbesondere in nordrhein
westfalen nicht sagen können ob sie doch
in den nächsten tagen sich ergeben wird
wo es möglicherweise eben nicht mehr
gelingt infektionsketten vollständig
nachzuvollziehen und tatsächlich auch
alle kontakte wir müssen ja sehen wenn
es auf einmal um hunderte oder tausende
kontakte quer durch die republik gehen
sollte oder was wir ja auch sehen nicht
vergessen in rom auch kontakte quer
durch europa in einer region wie
norditalien wo es sehr regen
berufsverkehr tourismus verkehr ja auch
gibt schweiz österreich die süddeutschen
bundesländer sind gerade vielfach auch
die bürgerinnen und bürger im urlaub in
den entsprechenden regionen in solchen
situationen keine sehen dann auch
passieren dass es nicht mehr möglich ist
alle kontakte nachzuvollziehen da sind
wir ausdrücklich noch nicht aber ich
finde es ihm wichtig dass wir uns für
diese situation vorbereiten und das wäre
dann zum beispiel im pandemieplan dann
auch die nächste beschriebene phase und
in den pandemieplan steht daneben auch
drin was informationen der bevölkerung
angeht was informationen der
gesundheitsberufe angeht der ärzte der
pflege
wie dort vorzugehen ist wie jeder seine
hausaufgaben auf welcher ebene zu machen
hat sie wissen dass viel auch auf der
rechtlichen kompetenzen und
verantwortung zuschreibung auf länder-
und kommunaler ebene ist im rahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und die
pandemieplanung sieht eben genau vor
wer ist für was verantwortlich
maßgeblich und setzt was um in welcher
phase und in welcher lage und eine
solche pandemie planung haben wir eben
insbesondere sehr ausgearbeitet für eine
influenza-pandemie und ich sage
ausdrücklich mal was immer durcheinander
geht da geht es nicht um die saisonale
grippe sondern eben um eine andere
influenza pandemie wie der
schweinegrippe die wir vor etwa zehn
jahren wenn deutschland in europa erlebt
haben
das ist eben genau dafür aufgearbeitet
ausgearbeitet worden aber weil das virus
ist nicht gleich ist kein grippevirus
corona virus aber zumindest die
symptomatik ist in vielerlei hinsicht
vergleichbar
und das macht es eben möglich durchaus
auch auf diese influenza pandemie
planung jetzt zurück zu greifen und sie
anzupassen
der kollege der minister es soll ja
knappheiten geben bei der ausstattung
mit mundschutz atemschutzmasken und
dergleichen
das gesundheitswesen tatsächlich
vorbereitet die große herausforderung
die wir gerade bei dem thema von
schutzausrüstungen haben ist die
situation dass alle länder auf der welt
gerade genau da bedarf haben und ich
vermute mal dass einer der größten
produzenten auf der welt genau für diese
schutzausrüstung in china ist so dass
auch daraus sich natürlich in der
aktuellen lage
dann folgen ergeben und wir haben da
zwei dinge wir brauchen zum einen
schutzausrüstung und die vorbereitung
für eine mögliche lage wie ich sie
gerade beschrieben haben in deutschland
und wir haben ja auch noch den weg so
nennen darf normalbetrieb wo er auch im
täglichen normalen abläufen bei
operationen und behandlungen
entsprechende schutzausrüstung
bekleidung notwendig sind
und das ist insgesamt in europa und auf
der welt da zu einer knappheit kommt das
ist offenkundig absehbar und wir sind
auch dort mit den ländern und den
verbänden im gespräch wie wir uns
bestmöglich darauf vorbereiten was
natürlich zu einer situation führen kann
wo man zumindest mal planbare eingriffe
und maßnahmen dann möglicherweise ein
stück nach hinten schiebt und vor allem
auch die akutversorgung sicherzustellen
hermann ist das stichwort vorbereitung
und kapazitäten wie schätzen sie die
kapazitäten der krankenhäuser momentan
ein auch somit isolieren fähigen
bereichen auch angesichts der laufenden
normalen grippewelle und zum zweiten
reisebeschränkungen grenzkontrollen und
ähnliches sagten sie glaub ich gestern
oder vor ein paar tagen ist noch nicht
der zeitpunkt ist das nach wie vor
aktuelle den ersten teil habe ich schon
wieder vergessen wird alt krankenhaus
entschuldigung
also der erste teil reisebeschränkungen
sie wissen nicht vergessen im roman mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen aus
frankreich der schweiz österreich
slowenien kroatien und eben auch italien
gesprochen über die situation was mir
sehr wichtig war dass wir zu einem
konsens dort kommen und da sind wir auch
zu gekommen dass es eben keine
generellen reisebeschränkungen oder gar
grenzschließungen geben soll ich habe
gerade die ja auch sehr dichte lage in
norditalien beschrieben
der schweizer kollege hat sehr
eindrucksvoll dargestellt wie viel
täglicher berufsverkehr alleine zwischen
der italienischen schweiz und italien
jeden tag stattfindet wie viele
verwandtschaftsbeziehungen ist über die
grenze gibt es gilt ja auch für andere
regionen oder ich hab gerade ja auch
schon beschrieben welche
urlaubssituation wir gerade für viele
auch nicht nur aber insbesondere auch
süddeutsche haben die gerade eben in
norditalien oder auch österreich
im urlaub sind und deswegen bin ich
dankbar dafür dass es gelungen ist auch
in einer einfach bewertung was es
verhältnismäßig was ist angemessen
auch zur aktuellen lage gemeinsam zu
sagen für den jetzigen moment jedenfalls
halten wir reisebeschränkungen nicht für
angemessen und verhältnismäßig denn die
wahrheit ist natürlich wenn eines der
länder in der region entsprechende
maßnahmen ergreifen würde setzte das
logischerweise auch alle anderen unter
nicht nur unter politischen sondern auch
ein vater ganz faktische zwang darauf
reagieren zu müssen das war mir schon
mal wichtig wir haben zudem miteinander
vereinbart dass wenn es auch
großveranstaltungen geht dass keine
generelle herangehensweise geben kann
sondern eine fall zu fall entscheidung
in der jeweiligen situation es gibt ja
ein fußballspiel das eben größere
aufmerksamkeit eher haben wird in der
champions league das jetzt ohne
zuschauer statt findet was natürlich
jetzt eine einzelfallentscheidung ist
aber ich finde es ihm wichtig dass das
tatsächlich situationsangemessen von den
behörden jeweils vor ort entschieden
wird so wie bei uns in deutschland im
übrigen auch die kommunen und länder
zuständig wäre wäre während und sind für
die frage wie mit großveranstaltungen
umzugehen ist was die frage angeht der
kapazitäten in den krankenhäusern ist ja
eine der großen aufgaben die wir gerade
haben und einer der hauptansatz punkte
die wir haben auch in der in der politik
die wir verfolgen möglichst viel zeit zu
gewinnen damit es nicht parallel zu der
aktuellen grippewelle und sie ist gerade
in deutschland unterwegs
daneben eine zusätzliche breite
belastung für das gesundheitswesen gibt
die sich daneben ergeben würde ich sage
noch einmal da sind wir noch nicht aber
wir müssen vorausschauend und das haben
wir den letzten wochen immer gemacht
natürlich auch jede weitere entwicklung
auch mitdenken aber auch dafür sehen
eben die entsprechenden pandemiepläne
weil sie fragten auch nach dem inhalt
entsprechende abläufe vor das eben wenn
man ja eine situation käme wo etwa
intensiv kapazitäten an eine grenze
kommen
daneben weitere schritte auf was
provisorien und anderes angeht ergriffen
werden könnten
dass man schwerpunkt versorger und
krankenhäuser für eine bestimmte
situation in einer region benennt und
vieles andere mehr und ich finde es
wichtig wir haben die planung dazu die
haben auch schon vor einigen jahren
gemacht er ist gerade schauen darauf
hingewiesen worden
ich habe manchmal den eindruck das sage
ich jetzt auch mal für die zukunft wir
sollten solche planungen vielleicht
öfter mal üben damit wir sie dann auch
in den konkreten situationen tatsächlich
auch schnell und gelernte umsetzen
können und mein eindruck ist dass und
geschieht unterschiedlich häufig in den
jeweiligen regionen
sie wissen vielleicht dass wir hier eine
neue abteilung gründen gerade auch im
bundesministerium für gesundheit gerade
auch mit dem fokus auf
gesundheitssicherheit und es war schon
vor dem corona virus mir ein anliegen
ein sehr bewusstes anliegen dass wir
tatsächlich diesem ganzen thema
vorbereitung auf epidemien pandemien
hier in deutschland viel viel mehr
aufmerksamkeit widmen und zwar nicht nur
innerhalb des ministeriums sondern vor
allem auch dann eben in der konkreten
planung und übungen und wir werden aus
dieser lage die wir aktuell haben
das kann ich jetzt schon sagen das gilt
schon für die letzten wochen und ich
vermute dass wir doch für die nächsten
wochen noch mehr gelten ziemlich viel
lernen dafür worauf wir uns noch besser
in zukunft vorbereiten sollten die
kollegin hinter der rechten kamera und
dann würde ich die frageliste mit blick
auf die uhr sah war das tv also zwei
fragen die eine ist gibt es tatsächlich
genug betten man hat immer die bilder
aus china im kopf wo wirklich 100 betten
nebeneinander stehen und hier gibt es
nur vielleicht 60 70 isoliert stark
isoliert zentren reicht es aus was wird
da getan und die andere frage in
rheinland pfalz ist im zug gestoppt
worden und
untersucht worden und sind da jetzt
tatsächlich gravierend gefunden worden
das ist ja schon der erste teil der
reise begrenzung also was bringt sie
dazu sagen also zum einen wir haben in
deutschland 7 40 betten für
hochsicherheits situation und der korona
virus erfordert das ausdrücklich nicht
richtig auseinander zu halten
mit diesen 7 40 betten für hoch
sicherheitsanforderungen übrigens haben
wir mehr als der rest europas zusammen
und mehr als fast jedes andere land auf
der welt auch das ist manchmal 47 klingt
immer nach vielleicht im ersten moment
wenig aber wenn wir da auch die
vorhaltung die wir in deutschland
betreiben vergleicht mit den
allermeisten anderen ländern unternehme
ich die usa ausdrücklich rhein in dieser
betrachtung dann ist das schon eine hohe
zahl aber für diese corona lage brauchen
wir gar nicht hauptsächlich oder
überhaupt hochsicherheit sondern ins
kontor intensiv und isolierstation dies
eben in vielen krankenhäusern in
deutschland gibt ja nicht nur in
unikliniken und nicht nur in maximal
versorgern sondern auch in vielen
anderen krankenhäusern in deutschland
und natürlich müsste man aber das ist
ich sage nochmal das ist ja in der lage
in der wir moment sind wo auch eine
grippewelle sich sehr unterschiedlich
entwickeln kann in der frage wie viele
schwere oder schwerste erkrankungs
bilder gibt es die dann auch eine
künstliche beatmung notwendig machen
oder zu schweren lungenentzündungen
führen
auch dort gibt es natürlich immer wieder
situationen wo die versorgungslage
angespannt ist wo es wo es dann manchmal
in der region im jeweiligen krankenhaus
dann auch provisorische lösungen braucht
das kann auch jetzt niemand ausschließen
aber ich will noch einmal sagen dass
alles das worüber ich hier gerade rede
ist vorbereitung
ich finde es aber wichtig ist
auszusprechen weil die bürgerinnen und
bürger ja die berechtigte erwartung
haben dass wir uns auf alle
entwicklungen vorbereiten und sie auch
mitdenken und das machen wir von anfang
an das haben wir von anfang an gemacht
wir haben uns leben im ersten moment
sehr stark auch in der umsetzung wie
natürlich auch in der kommunikation und
begleitung konzentriert auf diese erste
phase jeden einzelfall ausfindig machen
die rückkehrer aus haan
das will ich noch mal sagen ist eine
maßnahme zentrale unterbringung
quarantäne die die bundesrepublik so in
der größenordnung nie vorher getroffen
hat sehr bewusst getroffen
aber wir müssen eben anerkennen dass
möglicherweise mit dem geschehen in
nordrhein-westfalen wir jetzt in eine
neue lage hinein kommen und das zweite
war hat der zug in rheinland-pfalz ich
kann ihnen jetzt ehrlicherweise stand
jetzt habe ich keine detaillierten
informationen zu der situation in
rheinland-pfalz ich kann ihn nur
generell zum zugverkehr sagen weil wir
vor zwei drei tagen auch die situation
am brenner hatten wo es nachts so ein
zwei stunden hieß der zugverkehr wäre
generell eingestellt worden
das war nicht der fall sondern und das
ist ja richtig wenn es ein konkretes
verdachtsmoment gibt daneben zu sagen
das machen wir bei flugzeugen übrigens
genauso dann wird eben der zug der bus
das flugzeug angehalten und dann müssen
auch alle passagiere erst mal
möglicherweise eben diese zeit hinnehmen
das ist erst mal lästig aber notwendig
bis bei einem konkreten verdachtsfall
wie in diesem zug am brenner und jetzt
möglicherweise in rheinland pfalz im
sichergestelltes ist das einfach ein
bestätigter ein begründeter verdacht
oder oder nicht aber ich finde es ihm
wichtig zu unterscheiden zwischen der
einzelmaßnahme aufgrund einer
begründeten lage war sich eine
symptomatik zeigt oder weil es einen
kontakt kette gibt mit jemandem der im
zug ist die sich gerade ergeben hat und
bekannt wurde oder generellen
reisebeschränkungen das ist ein
qualitativ wichtiger unterschied und wir
sind in richtiger weise bei der
verdachtsunabhängigen maßnahme da okay
vielen dank schönen abend dankeschön